here on politics now we're going to take
a look at the homelessness issue
in clark county in the city of las vegas
meredith spriggs is here with cara dad
to talk about what is happening as we
move beyond the pandemic to some extent
that doesn't mean certainly the issue of
homelessness of low income housing has
gone away in fact
perhaps it's gotten even more
challenging so let's just start if we
can meredith by talking about what is
the situation on the street right now
what are you seeing first hand uh in our
community
thank you for having me on of course and
full disclosure we used to be a street
outreach agency and we switched and now
do gardening so we are not on the
streets every day
my experience with street homelessness
currently as an organization
is what we see in the downtown alley
which is off six and carson and i also
am a downtown resident so it's really
kind of my little pocket of the world
and what i see
is what i know so what we're seeing is
we're seeing
a big increase in visible street
homeless and i always
judge it by the time of the month so i'm
seeing them at the beginning of the
month and
traditionally that's been when people go
indoors they get their pay whatever so
we're still seeing that
no break at the beginning of the month
and then an uptick
in um the substance abuse is what we've
just seen in our little little pocket
and that isn't to say that all homeless
are doing no of course not drugs
but it's just more visible than i feel
like in your face than it's been
traditionally
now i mean there's an anecdotal aspect
to it but there's also just the i guess
the reality on the street and i'm
wondering
if in your discussions and what you're
seeing how much the pandemic has played
into what we're seeing in terms of folks
just not being able to afford places to
live and be able to find
work to stay in shelter or find a
shelter that's available for them
it's very interesting we were the
actually only organization in the
initial shutdown that was going out and
checking on folks and so people didn't
even know what was going on
yeah they didn't know what's going on
they didn't know how to access services
and now that things have opened
certain agencies aren't even fully
opened for appointments social security
for example
so if people have identities stolen
which you need
to get into a place to rent you can't
get that now because you can't just
say walk in or if you go to the dmv what
we've been doing um to help our clients
is we get in line at like 4 30 or 5 in
the morning
so we can get in the building to get
their id
that day to hold their hands sort of
almost through the process well they
they meet us at eight because that's
when they open and then they get in
because there are no appointments right
now at the dmv until later on in the
fall
and so yeah what does one do if you
can't get your id and you can't access
those resources
you're just stuck in this never-ending
loop of homelessness if you have no idea
you can't get a job
bank situations whatever the case may be
you know even during the pandemic there
were efforts made the city the county
and other
organizations to expand where there was
the
the um they set up that area right by
cashman field
uh content yeah the tent sort of area
there
um so it seemed like there were some
good faith efforts at that time
how much of that from what you're seeing
is following through
now is there still that push that that
effort
on a government level or on a non-profit
level by other organizations
to um to address this issue absolutely
and i do know
the tent that was a big debacle you know
that made worldwide press is kind of uh
and people mocked it but something that
people didn't know on the back end a lot
of what we got
was covid cares funding so it was basic
needs assistance funding through the
feds and that was a great surge into our
community
lots of organizations got it we got it
and we're able to expand through it
um but it we couldn't put it towards
permanent housing or permanent
structures so that was unfortunately a
federal hang-up
so even though all that money came
through then other programming we've had
to supplement
to keep it going or to create something
more permanent for our clients so that
has been the struggle
for the government entities okay now
what and so there have been other monies
like the marijuana funds to go into the
community that will help with that
and so i know the county and the city
are being proactive to try to figure out
okay
now what's the next step we got this
money we can't keep it our time just ran
out actually on the 30th of june so
we're all
now doing our reporting deadline but all
pencils down we can't spend any more
money
now what do we do seems like a lot of
red tape for something that has been an
issue for a long time in the city
absolutely absolutely in this community
as a whole and it's not just our
community
many other communities struggle with
this too is that you don't have
community buy-in
and the communities that successfully
and homelessness are where they have
buy-in
from the private sector and the faith
sector here we don't really see that
as much and so what we have is the
little bit
that our government can can give us from
the federal level on down
and so that just isn't ever going to be
enough like we still are always going to
have a gap
before the pandemic the city passed
some controversial ordinances which i
know you were involved in fighting
against
with regards to camping on the streets
uh issues of homelessness sleeping on
sidewalks and so forth
they passed the impression i got from
talking with folks at city hall at least
is that
you know the pandemic overshadowed a lot
of that and their priorities were
elsewhere what is happening on the
ground from that level are those rules
actually still being enforced are you
speaking with folks that live on the
street that are that are homeless
that are dealing with this on a somewhat
regular basis
and what are their concerns we are and
what we're seeing is it's getting harder
for us to find people the
handful of people that we have that are
literally street homeless that were case
managing
um they'll get rousted or they'll get
moved or they'll get you know threatened
with citations and so then they move
to areas and so then we can't find them
or they get arrested and we can't find
them so it's really hard to get things
done when people are in jail and
unfortunately this is another
red tape loophole thing that we have
going on with the feds if someone is in
jail over 45 days they get taken off the
community housing list
so you basically by throwing people in
jail then are disqualifying them for
housing if it's for an extended jail
stay
so it's it's really hard it's it's yeah
well
you you know you know when i've spoken
with whether it's uh law enforcement
city officials the impression i've
gotten is that they aren't really
enforcing it they're
threatening to enforce it um is that the
in your opinion anyway the best way to
go about this in terms of trying to
motivate people who are living on the
street who are who don't have a home or
whatever the case may be
to get assistance i always say we've
failed
if law enforcement is doing our housing
or threatening
to do you know you do this or else and
if all you have in your tool belt is a
hammer everything looks like a nail so
they are law enforcement they are doing
what they are told to be they are not
uh homeless service providers i say this
is
it's not working we can see it's not
working if you look out on the streets
anybody can see it's not working
if you threaten people they're just
going to run away that's not a good
option so as homeless providers i also
own this we failed too because you know
if we're here
that means we haven't come up with
better solutions we haven't created more
housing
and they're just doing basically a
knee-jerk reaction of what the community
is calling for which is hey
get these people out of here now you
mentioned initially
you were hinting at the efforts by
governments to use some of the federal
funding
and i understand those are discussions
that are ongoing kind of getting off the
ground at a city and county level to use
this federal money
to help where is the best place in your
opinion to put that money
to do the best good the most good
housing and transitional housing but
that's a long-term fix i mean
is there a short-term solution that can
be done
that would alleviate some of the
pressure
i can't really think of that anymore no
it's just because
because what we've done or just you know
work with landlords right now also
affordable housing is a thing
i used to be when i had clients coming
in that had a fixed income
of 733 a month they could find a place
even in downtown
now that's next to impossible and it's
getting more competitive for renters as
homes are going away
so it's just hard to even rent now so
how are people to find that so maybe
working
with landlords to get a master lease
would be great for now and you could
even
i know um some of i want to say it was
well care welcome had a master lease on
an old super aid in town so they had
covered rooms
for those at risk and so they could put
them in there so those are hotel rooms
that have been repurposed they have a
master lease with the
the main agency they case managed they
make sure everything is good
and that's what they did here in la they
called it project room key they did the
same thing
put people in hotel rooms case manage
them and then that gave them kind of
respite until they could find housing so
they weren't out on the streets
uh you were talking about gardening tell
me tell us quickly the viewers about
caridad gardens and what that is and how
that helps sure
i always want everybody to come but so
i'm really excited
and i'm so thankful clark county was
administering the grant they picked us
to get uh more funds so we are expanding
so we currently have a farm operation
it's an indoor hydroponic farm anybody
can come down and take a peek at it if
you want just let us know
but it's at 11th in fremont so at the
back of the bunkhouse lot or behind
11th street records right across from
the ferguson's downtown they're off 11th
in fremont
and so we grow produce half of it is for
anthem medicaid members living within a
two mile radius because that's a food
desert
they get free produce anthem tracks are
overall health outcomes and metrics
the other half we sell for sale to the
bars and the restaurants so your mint
your basil any of those craft cocktails
that you're getting at any of those
fremont east bars
we've probably grown some of that
produce for that and so that covers the
cost of who we hire we hire formerly
homeless
right now we're serving veterans with
u.s vets so we hire them it's a jobs
reintegration program and then we have
on wednesday's wellness wednesday
programming so we have heart math
meditation
we have trauma recovery yoga and we have
workouts with our partners the lv bar
stars
i joke that it's like disneyland people
that work for us but we know our client
base and this is where i think
programming has gone wrong
we've catered it to them we asked them
what do you want
what do you need we listen to them and
we literally change it each month we
have a team meeting where we sit with
them we say what can we do better
what's not working what do you want to
do and that's how we go from there and
so that's i think the success in our
sauces
we just ask and we listen and and when
when you talk to them
i guess as a final question what do they
say they need
the most what is there aside from just a
place to live which is understandable
but
what is the biggest complaint the
biggest concern they have on a
day-to-day basis
i think it would blow everybody's mind
but i think the viewers need to hear
this
when we did our surveys at the end of
the last semester with our practicum
student
the number one thing they needed was
community
they were lonely people in the streets
are lonely
people indoors are lonely what have we
done with our society
that we are so focused inwardly we're
individualized you know
we're on our phones we're segregated
isolated and now we're dehumanized now
we're other rising
and i think not only do we need these
great programs and the government we
need it's a combo right
it's kind of like that that rubik's cube
of what you need
or tetris i guess it would be tetris to
put it all together to work
so it's you need the housing you need
the supportive services you need the
support of
the government and the private
private citizens and you need community
to surround them and help them
interesting meredith thanks for coming
in appreciate it thank you thank you for
having me